Avengers phase two still going strong
we've had four we've had Iron Men now
we've come to America Captain America
the Winter Soldier so Captain America
the Winter Soldier is the sequel to
Captain America and it's caps first
movie where he is in modern time by
himself he's not working with the
Avengers he's not taking on Nazis in
World War two he is in our time now and
it's his movie I was really looking
forward to seeing that I wanted to see
how cap deals with modern times when
he's you know doing his thing
what kind of his thing he's still
working with shields and that's a big
part of the movie caps the guy they send
into your deal with the big [ __ ] I love
seeing it the first mission he does he's
just running he's smacking dudes around
you're like Captain America's a badass
he's throwing that shield and badass you
in impossible ways there's no way to
boomerang that shield around like he
does and catch it and have it come back
to ya I'm like I want to call [ __ ]
on that but it's so cool you don't think
of it you don't pick it apart you just
go I want the shield the reality you
should probably want the skills more but
I want that damn shield this movie makes
Captain America's shield hands down the
coolest instrument in the Marvel
Universe sorry me young the hammer its
cap shield now and they could have just
had it as simple as cap works with
shield now there's this Winter Soldier
he has to take that out and it gets
wrapped up in a nice little boat like
you think you should be but it's not
like that cap working with shield shows
that they really have conflicting
ideologies I loved seeing how Captain
America dealt with shield it gave
Captain America personality and it's a
big part of what made this movie great I
don't say that lightly there's so much I
loved about this movie even the action
scenes were great the car chases were
exciting cars would flip up and land on
their side when the sound in the movie
makes the action scenes really hit hard
I gotta give credit to the sound fo
these cars would go up and slam on the
sides he's just like pshh ow I hope they
had airbags Falcons in this movie he's a
military guy too it is really cool to
see Captain America be like hey we're
both War vets and he kind of finds a
kindred spirit in this guy if you like
it's the beginning of a really strong
friendship between these two Winter
Soldier is kind of like the tyrant in
Resident Evil 2 the tyrant in Resident
Evil 2 you're going about the adventure
you're going about the game then
randomly this tyrant will crash through
the wall and you have to expend a bunch
of ammo that you're trying to say and
then time
and goes away and then rinse and repeat
a couple times that's pretty much the
Winter Soldier he just comes in to cause
problems and then he's gone it was
badass when he was there and I liked how
he tied him with the story that's cool
the disappointing thing is that he's not
in it enough to call the movie Captain
America the Winter Soldier
if Winter Soldier wasn't actually in
Captain America the Winter Soldier
Captain America would still have to deal
with the bigger picture problems that
are happening in this movie I feel like
the overall plot wouldn't be much
different in that case it should have
called this movie captain america [ __ ]
yeah that'd be a good and accurate title
do you have to watch Captain America the
First Avenger to get what's going on in
this movie I'd say yes and more than a
couple of occasions you should watch the
first one Captain America the Winter
Soldier though does what his sequel
should do it steps it up in every sense
of the word better characters better
plot better villains better action they
don't montage through the cool action
scenes it was exciting it was fun and
made Captain America one of the biggest
badasses in Marvel seriously characters
like Captain America that are so Boy
Scout they usually don't interest me I'm
like sorry Leonardo I like Raphael
Michelangelo or Donatello better this
one I'm like caps awesome and so is his
shield guys I am so glad to give the
first one of the year Captain America
the Winter Soldier is awesome tacular
alright guys usually I'd ask you a
question about Captain America but
here's how this is going to go I just
hit 500,000 subscribers it's half a
million subscribers and that is badass
and you're all badass for being there
with me you guys make this YouTube
channel thrive you make it grow and you
you make my heart grow three sizes like
the grinch scale and [ __ ] seriously
you're all great I love you I want to do
something special for you guys I was
like what should I do for half of this
five hundred thousand do is half a
million a lot of people have asked me to
do a Q&A you know you asked me a
question and try to answer it in video
form so I want to do that I'm not saying
I'm gonna get it up this week it might
be a couple weeks out this might take a
little while to get to you guys but I
will get to you guys so we're gonna do
an official Q&A so if there's something
you want to know about me a question you
want to ask ask in the comments section
below on this video comment below and
let me know as I said and again thank
you for getting me to 500,000
subscribers it's us it's you and me
we're going to go for a million and do
what I've wanted to do all this time
which is take movie reviewing back for
the common folk and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more